citizens of the reject Nation Tara
Erickson is back once again hi we are
gonna watch Monsters University for the
10th anniversary I didn't even realize
until I pulled it up on Disney P we are
celebrating a a milestone today cool I
didn't know that so before we hop into
the skies leave a like on the video and
after you leave a like make sure to
subscribe and also ring that bell
ring the bell now if we could just get
the song to pop up again in this movie
like it did in the water boy would be
good it was the best also while you're
at it be sure to check out Terra on
social media on the YouTubes and check
out La eats and drinks which is Tara's
online food Excursion Extravaganza and
if you want to get the full experience
of Monsters University with us see
everything that doesn't make these
reaction highlights come on over to
patreon.com the real rejects sync up
with your own copy it's a lot of fun
over there we also got a bunch more
stuff that we react to and review and
all that good stuff watch lungs reaction
highlights included without further Ado
Tara are you ready to go back to school
ready to get schooled not really but I
am ready for Monsters me too let's do
this thing
frighten Elementary
it's so pretty where they live I know is
it fall is it Autumn I want to go to
there is it almost Halloween Mike
Wazowski thanks
oh my God he's so cute little monkey
get your field trip buddy
Jeremy you and me okay no biggie Haley
oh somebody be Mike's friend Russell
Wazowski we carpool oh
oh it looks like it's you and me again
Mikey's so sweet
we scare because we care I'm in a
haunted house Facebook group called that
this is where we collect the scream
energy to power our whole world whose
job it is to go get that scream
[Music]
yes
hahaha
oh dang it the grown-up adult Monsters
the a squad I just happen to be a scare
I learned everything I know from my
school Monsters University it's the best
scaring school there is you wish via
Tech's the best
stop right there don't cross over that
safety line human children are extremely
toxic whoa
[Music]
foreign
you don't belong on a scare floor
ah he's just as much a monster as you
yeah and also where's the teacher Mrs
Graves Michael went over the line yes
[Music]
go wrong yes
atta boy Mike
[Music]
good distraction
what
you look so happy oh my God that's the
greatest face it's a nice transition
there I didn't even know you were in
there
wow I didn't even know you were in there
nice not bad that's nice hey he's not
invisible anymore that's some Beautiful
Textures in this too yes everything
feels like you could squish it
[Music]
varsity band killing it there absolutely
some monsters probably got to join the
band
it's a little Samwise moment cute if I
take one step further oh
[Music]
one small step for the University one
giant leap for Mike Wazowski for Monster
kind
this is a gorgeous campus oh my God so
pretty
what where are they this is awesome yeah
what part of the country is this tell us
now we want to go there learn
[Music]
ing
oh that's cool making doors let the
crown jewel of mu the scaring schools
look at the teeth on that Arch this is
what it was like for us at scare Academy
you know
scare games a super intense scaring
competition they're crazy dangerous you
get a chance to prove that you are the
best so fired up right now yeah
roar oh no what what hey there I'm your
roomie name's Randy Boggs take whichever
bed you want I wanted you to have first
dibs
oh if I do that in scaring class I'll be
a joke no it's it's totally great you
gotta use it really yeah but look at the
glasses they give it away yeah yeah man
I
can't wait to get started
oh that looks so pretty why does this
have to be not real I know I want to go
there where you want to go I want them
to build that and like just like you can
go in there and like eat food eat
Monsters University food oh my God
please make it happen I can't be late on
the first day
oh oh it me sluggy needs some shoes or
something skates yeah or a hoverboard I
am Professor Knight and I do not scare
easily
whoa
Professor McGonagall
she's only broke the all-time scare
record with the screaming that very can
whoa at the end of the semester there
will be a final exam fail that exam and
you are out of the scaring program oh
limited time kids who can tell me the
properties of an effective Roar the
Roars resonance the duration of the Roar
and the
[Music]
I love him Mr Sullivan Jimmy Sullivan
like Bill Sullivan the scarer he's my
dad oh Nepal baby
aren't you
ready
oh are they from Fear Tech your attack
dummies
oh sorry about that buddy why are you in
my room your room this is my this is not
my room oh aren't you the Scare Pig
You're Gonna Take It To The River Roar
Omega Roar the top fraternity on campus
a mega roar
now we're on an adventure
wow
[Music]
oh my God I want to live in this land so
bad like everything is so pretty and
awesome rarely have I wanted to just
jump into the screen more
[Music]
yes
ten points to Spooky door you want your
state of Kai material freshman thanks no
no no no no he's an Omega owl guy we saw
him first no way we did I'll take it
from here
Johnny Worthington president of Roar
Omega Roar Hey You See Me Ride the pig
but you might want to hang out with
someone a little more your speed they
look fun uh I'm a hater nah
I'm gonna scare circles around you this
year okay I'd like to see that you will
yeah go hang out with Nathan Philly and
you jerk there's nothing that'll get you
going like spite
now here is a Monster who looks like a
scarer
uh-huh I think you should scare people
that way what's up kids
monster
just do that take out your retainer and
wave it around yeah pretty scary yeah
embrace the horrors of Orthodontics
[Music]
you gotta apply yourself Sullivan
so many great details like I just want
to pause and just scrub all the frames
so awesome
zombie snob
silverback gorilla yes yes way to go
Mike
one frightening face there's not a scare
and make
who's fallen behind I'm gonna destroy
that guy well then you'll get this back
right away it's time to start delivering
on that Sullivan name oh you know what
Sully turn is back on Mike but I
guarantee you Mike's not going to turn
his back on solely
I believe you Tara in the scare
simulator
oh no oh a child's scarier than any of
them what is that thing
oh here we go
catch it all the time in the world
yeah all the Time in the World Is Right
holy junk
oh my God the scream all the screams are
in there
oh this is not good I'm a seven-year-old
boy
this particular child is afraid of
snakes emit would make him cry alerting
his parents exposing the Monster World
destroying Life as We Know It uh
I cannot recommend that you continue in
the scaring program good day but I'm a
Sullivan I'm sure your family will be
very disappointed
find a new Legacy although to be fair
they could have stored those more safely
yeah like in a cabinet what do you lack
is something that cannot be taught
you're not scary
oh you will not be continuing in the
scaring program let me try the simulator
I'll surprise you I doubt that very much
oh we'll see about that lady Dragon Lady
you got it coming for you some say that
a career is a scream can designer is
boring unchallenging a waste of a
monster's potential open your taxes
uh Rich history of scream can design
oh it's so sad he has to stare why does
window at straight at the school look
scary I know
right yes
yeah man put your name in the tri-wizard
cup Harry get in there the Goblet of
Fire we're closing down sign up so we'll
see you all wait
signing up oh yes the next winning
fraternity of the scare games the
brothers my brothers of uzma Kappa
yeah kid looks like Russell if I win you
let me back on the scaring program and
what would that prove that you were
wrong yeah that you suck if you win I
will let your entire team into the scare
program uh Sully you got to get in there
now man yeah if you lose you will leave
Monsters University deal all right Mike
we need six guys right sorry Chief we
count bodies not heads that dude counts
as one
[Music]
ouch
thank goodness I need you on my team I'm
already on a team uh that's how it all
happens
the star player has just arrived no way
we're shutting down signups okay is he
on your team or not
fine yes she's on my team
Hmm this is a fraternity house hey there
teams I bet you it's so clean in there I
love that there this is okay technically
we haven't actually had a party here yet
but when we do we'll be ready
oh man excellent timing do you pledge
your souls to the uzma Kappa Brotherhood
wow
oh geez Mom we're doing an initiation
well carry on just pretend I'm not here
this is my mom's house excellent can't
wait to start scaring with you Brothers
[Music]
oh all right Sally thank you sir you're
gonna buy another replace that it's the
first event of the scare games where do
they want us to meet of all the sewers
on campus this one has always been my
favorite it's called sewer hunting
that looks awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
underground monster fights
the toxic
[Applause]
yeah
movie and in real life
I'm gonna beat you over that Finish Line
get ready to eat my dust one last thing
scares work in the dark
oh man yes
oh nice good luck ladies thanks we're
gonna rip you to pieces what yep oh
why are you guys going so fast shouldn't
you like slow and precise
oh
God it's gonna be tough for the slithery
ones
[Music]
mustache that bubble butt
oh geez oh my goodness
[Music]
no help him oh man go go go come on get
out of there
oh gosh this looks so painful
[Music]
what does that do to your insides
oh whoa
take that without you are you Delirious
I beat you
your whole team has to cross the finish
line
yeah guys who's my Kappa has been
eliminated no wow Jaws State Akai has
been disqualified what the use of
illegal protective gel is cause for
elimination
is back in the games it's a miracle
truly truly a miracle your luck will run
out eventually not if you guys learned
to work together as a team that's right
whip him into shape Mike in the next
event if even one of us gets caught
we're all out do exactly what I do
foreign
love it
oh boy and in this event you do not want
to get caught by the librarian
quiet
oh those teeth What's So Scary About a
little old library
yeah she looks like Ursula I said
oh yeah
whoa
poor unfortunate soul
[Music]
s
oh man
oh come on oh Jesus jump
[Music]
all right damn it
the Only Rule is don't get caught so
noticed and caught are different now go
get it kids
oh my goodness goodness somebody's gotta
get the flag though
[Music]
we did it didn't we forgot the flag Mike
ah
what
and who's my Kappa live to scare another
day
it's starting to surprise her
hello
these guys are crazy
yeah buddy yeah
party like mascara
take that retainer Out Boy let's do this
yeah
[Music]
I love the goth club yeah you're joining
his then I would
oh
[Music]
come on Sullivan Sully
little Gangnam Style
yes
come on come on he got the flag for
y'all there we go Sully come on yes come
on buddy let's go
[Music]
oh
is there like a little one that's like
him oh anywhere
that's a great POV it's awesome the
surprise team of the scare games who's
macappa come on over guys you did it
goes
I thought you were a bunch of nobodies
but boy was I wrong let's hear it for
uzma Kappa
[Applause]
do it man is that gack
what
what wow
oh man
I find that kind of adorable but I know
it's embarrassing for them
[Music]
you guys they're the bad guys yeah these
guys jerks I want you to stop making us
look like fools hey you're making
yourselves look like fools cease and
desist with our likeness rights yeah if
you really want to work for a scare
company they're always hiring in the
mail room nope you're gonna work in the
mail room Nathan Fillion no matter how
much we train we'll never look like them
we're built for other things
oh 1200 Dark Avenue can't let the
bullies win yeah it takes nothing to be
born scary
we're going on a little field trip
I love the designs of their cars I got
like two three grills or like extra
headlight eyes have fun kids Obama
always has rollers in her hair
yeah that's right Mom
foreign
that's the real terror
getting arrested yeah Locked In The
Slammer
all right yeah put put it to the real
test get in a door and scare a kid
they're going into the human world and
they don't even look scared Yeah man
they prose oh yeah they're gonna learn
so much
the best scare is use their differences
to their advantage
ah yeah wowie cool Bob Gunderson I still
have his rookie card me too doesn't have
a speed anymore but this technique is
Flawless
ah did we just become best friends
bonding I've been a real jerk so have I
we could be a great team
we just need to start working together
oh what what are you doing up there
I can't go back to jail
getting inspired
[Music]
provide a distraction somehow hey there
you go Sully there we go yeah
start the car stop the bar the car start
the car oh okay oh
[Music]
okay go um
let's spray let's do it yeah
it's breaking everywhere we can oh all
right now we're getting the juice
heck yeah all right new threads that's
what I'm talking about
fresh drips
looking good
looking more than okay
Sully's never look so happy the kids in
the bathroom
[Music]
I love it it's our Rocky Montage scare
the little kid a boy's a teenager huh
the teenager will rip you apart yes
[Music]
that's awesome yes stay hidden take
cover and stay out of sight you got 10
seconds kiosk pile of leaves standing
out in the open
hey angry poodle gas clown yes in the
morning that's what I'm talking about
killing it nice
hey
yes use those cups
time to go to work all right my man
[Music]
I love this drum line with this Montage
yeah I want to see the band yeah
ah damn tough luck Chris Kringle
sounds good
also good damn it also good not bad
you've been taught well which leads us
to the final event the scare simulator
will prove who's the best
Mike has never gotten his chance after
you lose no one will remember you maybe
but when you lose
no one will let you forget it
boy that is a good point
it is
you're gonna talk to this guy yeah who's
mccapp is going to be huge in no time
I hope there's no hard feelings tomorrow
each of you must prove that you are
undeniably scary one of you is not
Mike
no he works harder than anyone do you
think he's scary he's the heart and soul
of the team do you think he's scary is
he any more or less scarier than the
other ones yeah I mean there's plenty in
there that don't look scary
time to forget all that just reach deep
down and let the scare you out now Mike
goes into training oh you're thinking
again from the gut yeah
[Music]
come on
this is studying
we're working here each simulated scare
has been set to the highest difficulty
level Oh no just like we planned I'll go
first then Don Mike's the one who
started all this and I think it's only
right if he's the one who finishes it
yeah Mike Finn is strong
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
remember your training
not great
[Music]
go
all right that was solid okay
[Music]
oh oh slick moves
okay
[Applause]
oh yes oh cool use those break dance
skills
ah awesome
[Music]
oh come on you got that kick good yeah
Sullivan and bobs
oh no foreshadowing yeah
child looks familiar somehow is that an
Easter egg
[Music]
oh it sounds like a lion and Thunder
yeah buddy
there you go
that's the last time I lose to you
Sullivan and the Rivalry is born don't
worry about anyone else
just go out there and show them what
Mike Wazowski can do yeah
nice pep talk soul you can do it buddy
your team's got your back don't take the
loss too hard
you never belonged here anyway
good sportsmanship
[Music]
yeah juice him up he's got fuel now
oh please don't mess up what are we what
was the plan
[Music]
okay oh boy
belong on a scare floor no one will
remember you you're not scary come on
yes
yes there you go
take that that Hard Scrabble yeah man
triple word score
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah my
you did it oh
[Music]
oh oh
that's gonna be weird you're gonna be
your teammate's father-in-law right
her stepfather there you go get plenty
of rest kiddo You Haven't Seen the Last
of Mike Wazowski
what
oh did he rig it
[Applause]
damn it I was ah damn I was just I was
thinking like why are my settings
different did you do this I
ouch why did you do this you'll get
better and better I'm as scary as you
you just wanted to help yourself well
what was I supposed to do let the whole
team fail because you don't have it
oh that burns yeah
[Music]
he could have done it
y'all go come clean give him another
shot
oh all right yeah he's gonna go through
the real thing you did what my team had
nothing to do with it it was all me I
expect you off campus by tomorrow
is that Helen Mirren oh yeah might be
what's going on someone broke into the
door lab what
oh no oh yeah
oh yes
oh dude
[Music]
thank you
you look funny oh
no
oh my goodness
no oh God
damn
what can you do this is a nice this is a
nightmare a toxicity
yeah wait
[Music]
misdirection of course do it Solly
Mike
no what
Mike uh oh
[Music]
or a Sasquatch
yes so pretty and so spooky spooky is
pretty John yes
my mistake of course it is come on buddy
let's get you out of here you were right
they weren't scared of me I did
everything right I wanted it more than
anyone
I could show everybody that that Mike
Wazowski is something special and I'm
just
not
oh they're just special in a different
way you'll never know what it's like to
fail because you were born a Sullivan
yeah I'm a Sullivan I'm the Sullivan who
flunked every test the one who got
kicked out of the program the one who
was so afraid to let everyone down that
I cheated
yeah
I asked Gary Mike but most of the time
I'm scared I'm terrified
oh how come you never told me that
before
we weren't friends before
[Music]
Sully here we go called him Sully
yes
they're still in there until the
authorities arrive this store stays off
no oh boy what if we scare them I mean
really scare them we could generate
enough scream to power the door from
this side yeah ah they're adults I can't
do this yes you can just follow my lead
let's go
let's do this
uh-huh
yes nice
oh creepy playing the hits
yeah all the tropes of a scary movie are
you ready Mike I can't yes you can stop
being a Sullivan and start being you yes
nice
amazing yeah buddy oh my goodness there
you go yeah that's some nuclear scaring
foreign
oh my goodness
oh
man
take that lady you only got one in your
life yeah who's scared now yeah
oh
nah that's Monsters Inc now
[Music]
oh
what's gonna happen to them that's for
the University president to decide
hey what's up
expelled yeah we really messed up art
scrabble's letting us into the scare
program hey he invited us to join next
semester
congratulations guys and that's not the
only piece of good news Sherry and I are
engaged
I don't want you to think of me as your
new Dad after all we're fraternity
brothers first this is so weird it is
you'll keep in touch
hit
no you're the scariest bunch of monsters
I have ever met hmm don't let anyone
tell you different
[Music]
that's so sweet y'all are okay
I'm okay just being okay
so long so
so long
huh
have we seen a Pizza Planet truck
anywhere
hey
I don't know a single scarer who can do
what you do and you think you're just
okay you pulled off the biggest scare
this school has ever seen that wasn't me
that was you it was us you're not scary
not even a little but you are fearless
yes and if Hard Scrabble can't see that
then she could I can just what yeah
the two of you did something together
that no one has ever done before
you surprised me
there is nothing I can do for you now
except perhaps wish you luck
oh you guys can go to Fear Tech now
yeah man
there is still one way we can work at a
scare company
oh the mail room yep yep you're always
hiring in the mail
this is better than I ever imagined I
think we break the all-time record in
our first year I'm talking about the
record for letters delivered
all right there he is
[Music]
yes working your way up the ranks
oh got a number too ah
flies with chili cheese fries scare
tryouts yes
screaming in the rain
[Music]
oh
oh Celia good luck on your first
bite thanks fellas
[Music]
step over the line you coming coach
you better believe it
[Music]
they get their own cards and everything
well done
I love it very lovely
what a delight that was so good yeah oh
it's so cute I feel so happy for him
yeah me too it's funny when this when
this first was coming out I was like hey
you know sequel monsters I'm sure it'll
be fine or whatever but this was so
charming and fun like it's great I love
this world that they've built and uh
just all the different little flourishes
and whatnot and and yeah like
God I wish I could just go walk around
that campus boy that's so pretty yeah I
love it yeah it's also super fun to see
how like him and Sully their
relationship how it started and then how
it is there was that one moment when
Sully really turned into becoming a team
member when they were on the roof and he
starts helping them like get uh when
they're being chased by the cops yeah
but before that he was like just a jerk
the whole time then they had to talk
because when you think of the first
movie you're like he's nice yeah he's
like a sweet guy and then you get to see
his change in this movie and I like that
yeah absolutely and I thought they they
played it you know in a way that uh felt
you know pretty graceful that worked
quite nicely I mean yeah they are like
archetypical but at the same time I
thought the way that they you know took
yeah the overachiever and the slacker
and then kind of forced them toward each
other yeah like me and you exactly Tara
you carry me throughout this life yes
yes uh and you know I I've been carried
by a lot of great people in this life
well I'm very very grateful for and I'm
grateful you are one you are my Mike
Wazowski oh so that means you're my
solely that's right that's right we're
so cute yeah yeah and I'm a nightmare
off camera
we haven't had the talk yet that's right
you still you got to give me that one
last inspirational speech I do I've been
writing it for years but you're still I
think you're still scary though
but yeah I know like seeing the way that
they ultimately took these characters at
this stage and then you know doing the
end Montage getting them to the point
where they are you know where we met
them the first time I just thought yeah
it moved really nicely toward all those
things and and yes it was Helen Mirren
all right ah you had it right yeah
there's a lot of a lot of places in here
is Aubrey it was Aubry Plaza I was like
she only had like five lines but I was
like that has to be Aubry Plaza yeah
yeah and there was that John
ratzenberger like I was sitting here
trying to like late in the movie I was
like oh yeah they're like Easter eggs
Pixar puts in everything yeah so there
was uh at least the John ratzenberger
voice was there as the yeti coming back
from the first movie and I swear he had
lemons on his tie for the yellow snow
cones but uh I didn't see that yeah or
something I don't know that's what it
looked like to me I could be wrong but
but uh but yeah I didn't catch the Pizza
Planet truck or the or the room at USC
or whatever the the the the classroom
where they all learned in like you know
but uh but just all the different little
flourishes all the different little uh
details and stuff like this is a movie I
would love to pause and scrub yeah
because like all just the monster
versions of like posters they'd have on
the walls or advertising and things like
that and just yeah all the different
design flourishes I thought were just so
fun and and imaginative and for you know
somebody who loves horror and who loves
monsters anyway like this is I mean they
made fun of them for being so cute but
like this is like the best kind of blend
of both it's like it is really fun and
bouncy and colorful but at the same time
like I I do like and and very much
appreciate just their take on this world
and all the different like fraternities
and sororities with all their you know
the way they went to to put you know the
actual Greek letters for some of it and
then they'd have like a spooky you know
concept as one of the letters and then
each one spells out a thing like this
yeah just like really well thought out
yeah I especially like when well of
course like the highlight of their scare
but using all those like horror tropes
like in a movie with a thing and then
the doll
um I don't know I just think this is
such a a creative film that still has uh
Pixar it does a really good job of this
it still has like a adults can watch it
and love it but it's still great for for
kids to be like
except Pixar does a nice job of making
it more High are like comedy and like
there's some high bar like throwaway
lines that it's not all just like
kid yeah it's not all fart jokes yeah
maybe you know what I mean no totally
because like this is and I'd have to go
back it's been a long time since I've
seen the original Monsters Inc and I
know it's a lot of people's one of their
top Pixar joints
um and here like you know because I
think anytime especially a company like
Pixar makes a sequel there becomes the
debate of like is it great though and uh
and this yeah I thought was really nice
because like it's easily accessible for
a young audience but you know if you're
an adult and especially if you went to
school
uh I think this will bring back yeah
just a lot of those nostalgic
experiences and feelings and and yeah I
thought they captured that campus life
in like a really fun way that does
definitely I think play to people who
have that experience as well as people
who might be looking forward toward that
experience yeah like man I wish I would
have went to a real school I just went
to performing art school and I was like
we didn't have the buffet thing people
tell me that they would have a cafeteria
of a buffet and they're like we could
get frozen yogurt at all times or frozen
or ice cream like crazy stuff and I'm
like oh man also why doesn't Disneyland
do that where they have like Monsters
University but Monsters University food
like Mario Kart land in Universal
Studios exactly The Lure do that come on
now make a special monsters land and
then plus you know we saw how the
cafeteria ran you could just take
whatever people discard put it right
back on the line yeah and then you save
on uh garbage disposal all that stuff
yeah I would eat people's leftover
monster food I mean especially if it's
at a discount like I'm trying to save
some dollars you know so as long as they
gave me a little cut on the price I'd
probably only eat the leftovers yeah
because it's expensive someone's got to
you know you don't want that stuff to go
to waste perfectly good all right what's
a little saliva am I right nothing yeah
but yeah I liked you know I mean it's a
kind of a classic story you know to to
you know opposite Misfits being put
together and then having to you know uh
elevate a a team of Misfits essentially
to finally Triumph but uh yeah I thought
the way that they did everything you
know the way that it moved was really
nice was like really just rich with uh
you know fun dialogue and fun references
and fun not like you know Easter eggy
references but yeah just like fun
flourishes of the Monster World I
thought the voice cast did a great job
yeah and yeah just like I love the world
like I I think that's that's the thing I
like the most is just the world like
this this felt like all the charms of
like a Harry Potter almost without
getting too heavy right it was still
like on the lighter side like I expect
in every Pixar movie that I'm going to
like cry sure and this one I didn't but
I still felt the heart and it didn't
feel like it was like out of place I
felt it like a lot like they do such a
good job of like giving you the heart
and doing like the pacing and putting it
at the right moment and building up
characters really nicely but I like how
Pixar does that yeah
um and at the end it was that like
rom-com where there's always somebody
running at the end somewhere to an
airport after a car to be like hey wait
um don't go yeah yeah and I like that
with them yeah yeah totally yeah like
it's interesting because Pixar you do
associate with this High bar of yeah
it's gonna be profound or something and
I definitely don't begrudge them like
something more fun more light like this
and especially when it is proportioned
to the way this particular movie is
proportioned I'm like yeah this was
totally everything it needed to be oh
oh
it's just getting to class little guy my
first day of class
and this school is over son you missed
it oh
those guys must have a difficult life oh
man
how's he ever gonna make it I don't know
I'm praying for him that's like me and
track and they would tell me to run and
then I'd end up with like a 15 minute
mile you've got to keep at it Tara
you're capable I mean I am more than you
can imagine but I don't want to do it
though I don't wanna I don't wanna run
down you're slacker Tara I am you are a
lazy bounce I know but now like yeah
this this isn't one of their more like
profoundly touching movies but I don't
think it really needed that and I think
the way that it the heart that it did
have I think was really lovely and uh
and yeah I like the way the plot
unfolded because it was you know you
have the magic of just discovering
Monsters University you know that there
will be obstacles but I like the kind of
linear nature of like okay we got to the
first scare class and then through our
own you know interpersonal you know
toxicity basically it was just because
we both got our own egos up you know uh
it leads to yeah this this chain of
events that gets them cast out of the
class and then they gotta earn their
back with the games and when the games
ended and I thought the games were
really fun they were really imaginative
yeah and then when the games ended I had
that thought because at first it was
like oh you know yes he did it
um and you're expecting that they'll you
know somehow win
um and at that moment even though I was
really excited I was like
seems like that was pretty easy though
it seemed like that like and that was
the point I thought the movie was going
to be like okay like you know the wrap
up it's fine but then to go that extra
uh Mile and be like okay Sullivan
cheated this and now we have to kind of
go off-road and prove ourselves in a
different way and there's like a a
deeper All Is Lost moment than just the
idea that Mike that Sullivan Sully
doesn't think Mike is actually scary
there's you know there's the actual All
Is Lost when they go through the real
door when Mike is like going off the
deep end and yeah and I like that that
doesn't result in like well you know
even though this was wildly against the
rules you guys did a great job and
you're just back like they still earn
the respect but they do get expelled
their teammates are spared the the fate
and then they work their way up you know
in their own natural way to becoming
scarers and in a way that also just
subtly touches upon the idea that even
though it's easy to get very wrapped up
in and passionate about you know
whatever chosen school or institution
you've gone to that's not the only way
to achieve success and I think more and
more in life that that has become
apparent it's like you know college used
to be like the the gateway to success in
this world and I think it's like nice
that they subtly included the idea that
like hey it's not the end of the world
if that's not your path and you could
still succeed in your chosen vocation
without that I was kind of a neat Nuance
you know then yeah I mean that's taken
care of in a montage by the end but I
think that's okay because we know it's
gonna happen we've seen the first movie
yeah and uh and yeah I thought the story
they chose to tell was was quite
conscientious and and made for great
opportunities for just a lot of fun yeah
I mean because like like I said it takes
nothing to be born scary just like how
they're trying to play like pretty
bullies like you don't have to do
anything to be born to look that way to
fit in a fraternity or whatever you just
are kind of born and those are your
genetics like solely but um it takes a
lot to have to work to be up to the
certain level you're not given
everything and even though solely had
more of a silver platter kind of a thing
handed to him with his name it wasn't in
inherently who he was so we still got to
see him grow with Mike through that and
people obviously who have to work their
way up and work a lot harder than the
rest and aren't nepo babies like you
were saying that that has aged up about
this movie they tend to be uh the the
washed out matter that like wins because
they've learned so much and I think when
you go through that you
um end up being obviously a better
person and just having more like Street
juice Street knowledge which is nice
yeah and two I mean him you know
actually learning actually putting in
some of the effort and then them coming
in at the end and actually just having a
sort of acceptance of like yeah you're
not necessarily scary but our teamwork
and and like your brains and my Brawn
work really well together and I thought
yeah that was just a nice uh yeah to
come off yeah the overachiever who's
been handed nothing and then the
underachiever has been handed everything
and then yeah the way they grew them
together I thought was quite nice and to
be in a time now where we talk about
nippo babies all the time we have these
like scandals about who gets into what
school because of what strings their
parents pulled and it doesn't go like
really far into that side of stuff but
yeah like it's it's funny that it has
become sort of even more relevant in
that aspect of the conversation yeah um
but yeah I just pulled up the IMDb
there's a lot of great voices I mean you
obviously Billy Crystal John Goodman and
Steve Buscemi from the original but like
I thought Helen Mirren did a great job
oh yeah uh and then I I thought I
recognized at the beginning I thought
that was John Krasinski as uh as I
believe that was him at the top the
Frank okay the guy who inspires him as a
kid and then uh you know Bill Hader was
the slug was yeah because they gave him
his own post critics which is fun and
then Bobby moynihan's in here you
pointed out Aubry Plaza Nathan Fillion's
like always obvious yeah um and then
Tyler Levine Alfred Molina I was trying
to figure out his voice I thought he was
a good addition you were right on
Charlie Day Charlie Dan Dave Foley who's
hilarious I love Dave Foley from Kids in
the Hall and stuff like that um Sean
Hayes is in here a lot of good voices
and yeah for those two to be paired
together as the two-headed guy I thought
was yeah it was a good call
um yeah man and like you said
representation matters when they were
looking into the school we had never
seen a scare team and then they're
they're the actual first scare team that
teams up together yeah so it's like oh
they can They're Gonna Change the World
they're scary stuff and that was I mean
without again that's something that's
also aged better you know all things
considered is when they go to Monsters
Inc and they're like oh wow literally
there is no one kind of monster there's
everybody using their own strengths I
was like this is a good message that
doesn't feel like it was you know
shoehorned in because of social media or
something right and I was like yeah this
is a really good point and it doesn't
necessarily solve everything but it is
like a good spiritual beat to have yeah
and it didn't feel expositional like it
was put there to force us to have the
information it just felt like a real
moment and I I really enjoyed that like
yeah now they are the representation for
like a team Duo and it's it's great it's
like and they have a story to tell like
they were kicked out a couple of times
so it used to be a jerk like just a
bunch of stuff that uh makes it more
heartfelt and that other scarers can
learn from to be like hey we're not
perfect we're just like normal people
and we messed up a lot yeah like we
considered ourselves failures but we're
still here now because we tried yeah
yeah exactly we put in the effort you
know we we clearly have something
between us even if it's not exactly what
everybody is looking for or expecting we
have worth and we have more than enough
you know Manpower and will between the
two of us yeah yeah and I just pulled up
I pulled up a list of the the Easter
eggs and stuff
yeah and then you had the A113 which is
that that room uh I forget it's like a
classroom in in USC or something like
that where a lot of them uh studied or
count lards there you go uh and there
was uh yeah the ball and all that stuff
and a few other things here you can
point out the other ones but I feel like
John ratzenberger uh the Pizza Planet
truck and the A113 are like always like
the main ones yeah but if there are any
more Pixar Easter eggs I mean feel free
guys to point them out to us
um but yeah any any stray thoughts
before we we hit it and quit it no I
would love to go to Monsters University
and obviously go to the cafeteria that's
the biggest thing that matters to me
that's actually I guess we'll close on
that is because we haven't really talked
about but I thought the animation was
absolutely gorgeous so amazing and like
the colors the designs of everything and
the way everything has like monstery
little flourishes and the use of color
like they come and it feels like full-on
like Autumn or something like that and
then when things take a turn for the
more dire then you'll get these moments
where yeah the world is all desaturated
and you'll just have like the blue
Banners are kind of popping but
everything else is very gray and when
they go into the human world at the end
it's very kind of gray and dreary like
you pointed out kind of enhancing those
tropes of a horror movie yeah uh yeah
and and for me like even though this is
easily like this is a family film it's
not scary per se I am all for like
kid-friendly horror stuff or stuff
that's like accessible to kids that can
kind of help to feed you on your journey
as a budding young horror fan I think
this is you know this is good for that
it's a good one yeah absolutely so uh
guys thank you for joining us on this
journey for this semester at school very
delightful and uh and I'm excited to
watch the original again now that we've
learned yeah me too
yeah I love the ride honestly I do
whenever we're in California Adventure
you know gotta take a break you gotta do
it yeah so leave a like on the video
guys don't forget to subscribe ring the
bell
and last but not least let's do a
picture of the day shut up let's do it
Mark Leach mark
I want to see your scare buddy I want to
see you know I mean who knows if you do
some kind of like slithery thing I mean
I'm just going off your name right now
and I'm sure a lot of people make leech
references think about it leeches are
pretty scary yeah and pretty useful so
you could be a a key member of the
monster's Community out here you know
you could like detox the monsters you
know God if they get to Juice Stop yeah
if they get all kid taminated yes you
can help remove that and also get some
scares in on the side you know I feel
like leeches are sort of like a horror
movie Trope certainly but they've also
got their place in the circle of life
and even though you are not scary in the
way that we are repelled by you you are
formidable and if you wanted to scare
the pants off of us I bet you could but
yeah I believe in you so much scare
energy to power this whole studio for a
year
we love you here at the Rio rejects the
scariest thing you could do I think
would be to end your pledge so don't go
that far don't do that you know I don't
come on now yeah I don't think you know
don't get the sense this universe is
about trauma right you won't traumatize
anybody or the kids or anything just a
little scare juice yeah just a little
bit yeah you know that's all you need
yeah that's all it's a good hearted
scare and I feel like that's what you
would deliver us yeah so be well Mark we
love you and we'll catch you on the next
one bye cheers
foreign